and joining us now from New York we're
pleased to welcome in an exclusive
former Trump campaign advisor Carter
Paige Carter it's good to see you
tonight I know you have not spoken out
about this house Intel memo yet or the
reaction to it what is your reaction
well my first reaction Laura when I saw
it was you know there kept there was a
lot of details that kept dripping out
and it sounded really bad and when I
actually saw it it was even worse than I
could have possibly imagined but then
what was particularly interesting is
sort of the next 48 hours after that
where part of the attack on chairman
Nunez and the committee was to come up
with any new new information to
discredit me and anything related to the
investigation or the the overall
investigation and all the great work
that hip C's been doing so it's it's
pretty pretty stark contrast between you
know getting the facts out there and
having you know still getting attacked
so it's pretty crazy this is this is
what Donnie Trump said earlier tonight
Edie referred to the interview he did
just a short while ago with Tucker
Carlson he was asked about you and this
is what he said this is a low-level
person who worked in a campaign this is
someone who I've seen the emails where
they said well this person's no longer
working on the campaign I believe one of
my family members responded who that
heck is that individual we've never even
heard of them so to use that again as
the basis to then try to attack the duly
elected president to do it then after
that person's no longer even part of a
campaign all of these people kind of
hang around they're gonna get their book
deal they want to be a part of something
so to utilize that person I mean they
seem like a great PAC see for that your
reaction to what Donny says you know a
low-level figure in the campaign I don't
think you ever have really disputed that
but your reaction well it was it was
really an impossible to help out in any
way because as you were alluding to the
attacks started almost immediately just
anyone with who had any connection or
had ever done any work positive or
otherwise in Russia was
constantly sort of the number one target
for attack so it was a you know became a
liability pretty quick what I would say
though is you know edit sort of alluded
to this early for in policy committee I
was really impressed with a lot of the
other people that were on the committee
and you know he as you as he mentioned
there was a few names that were
mentioned but really the people that
came on are in the early months were
pretty incredible and there was only one
meeting though right I mean this was
kind of slapped together in 24 hours my
I talked to one of the people involved
in it earlier tonight and this was kind
of thrown together really fast cuz like
we got to have a list of people were
advising us and this is when not a lot
of people were helping out Trump in the
spring of 2016 and so they came up with
this list and you guys had one meeting
at the Trump International I understood
but after that there was no formal
gatherings of this group is that correct
that you actually raised an important
point Laura I should have I should have
clarified correct one one point that
edit alluded to that one meeting I
actually had previous you're in Hawaii I
was in well I haven't said where I was
but if it's been real okay okay but
Carter you know what I'm getting I'm get
what I'm getting at is you were put on
this list and your past work that you
did in Russia we'll get into that later
raise the red flag for the in the FBI
apparently had been watching you for
some time okay so we we fast-forward to
July and you go to Moscow you say you
were invited to give a speech at the
college here when you went there did you
meet with government officials or people
connected closely with Putin so I I gave
a speech and the there was one senior
government official who spoke after me
he was walking out of the the building
after he gave his speech and we had a
very brief conversation for less than 10
seconds you know it was really a
exchange of pleasantries but I you know
a lot of the things he was talking about
you could tell there were pot there were
positive opportunities on the horizon
in terms of us-russia relations session
was that Igor Sechin no I've never met
section in my life oh my go so that's in
that so just so people know and it means
I find this to be fascinating that in
this fake dossier there is an entire
paragraph and I believe it's on page 31
where it says that in terms of substance
of their discussion Igor Sechin who's a
very former KGB guy president of Rosneft
the state-owned oil company said that
the rosna president was so keen to lift
personal and corporate sent Western
sanctions imposed on the company that he
offered page Trump's associate the
brokerage of up to 19 percent privatized
stake and Rosneft in return and page had
expressed interest and confirmed that
that that it were Trump elected
president then sanctions on Russia would
be lifted that's right from the dossier
Carter and I think a lot of people hear
about the dossier they don't know what's
in it
so you're saying tonight that you have
never met Igor
I always forget his name section you've
never met him I've never met him in my
entire life and what's interesting about
if you do the math on that yeah 19% had
a market value of about 11 billion
dollars so if you think I'm gonna be yet
get paid off some way that seems like a
pretty pretty hefty sum you know that's
pretty good yeah borrow some money from
you someday Carter hold right there we
have a lot more to talk about and it's
fun it's actually fun to read through
this dossier because it's like whew
crazy stuff